bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on l'a vu les
quatre contamination augmente de jour en
jour en île de france par exemple
selon vous est ce que le gouvernement
veut aller plus loin dans les
restrictions sanitaires
écoutez on remarque que quelques
semaines et depuis les derniers jours en
augmentation assez importante est assez
inquiétante du nombre de cas de kobe
dans en ile de france et est donc dans
la france entière et dans certaines
régions comme le sud est et qu'il va
falloir effectivement monté d'un cran
sur les sur les sur les restrictions et
du coup évidemment imposer le port du
masque et de manière plus générale dans
une tribune publiée par nos confrères de
libération look un collectif de médecins
plaident pour le port du masque dans
tous les lieux collectifs clos est ce
que c'est une des solutions pour
ralentir la propagation
le port du masque est finalement la
solution miracle la solution directe qui
en a pas qui arrivera le vaccin pour
l'instant on joue en défense donc avec
les outils qu'on le combat et le plus
efficace pour l'instant ça a été le port
du masque est donc les tests aussi à
tester et comme comment dire et porter
des masques et pour l'instant ça
fonctionne donc du moins on arrive à
contingenter un petit peu l'épidémie
comme ça donc c'est la seule solution
efficace qu'on aime c'est la seule qu'il
faut prendre et d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement a pris les mesures parce
que un olivier ferrand a rappelé que
désormais il faut porter un masque pour
les personnes âgées et pour les
personnes fragiles pour les personnes
dans les lieux publics dans les lieux
clos et dans les lieux très fréquentés
et c'est la seule façon de dandy dé
l'épidémie est ce que le dépistage est
aussi une solution
oui bien sûr le dépistage est une
solution alors on sait que on s'améliore
de jour en jour de semaine en semaine on
le fait de plus en plus vite mais on ne
fait pas encore assez s'est pas encore
suffisamment simple de se faire tester
mais les choses s'améliorent petit à
petit et et c'est inévitable
il faut il faut passer par là parce que
c'est la seule façon vraiment de 2,2
de dépister des dca et des clusters et
ainsi de les confiner rapidement il ya
aussi la flambée des prix une possible
pénurie quant aux masques gants les
professionnels de santé tire la sonnette
d'alarmé
comment est ce que le corps médical m'a
justement se préparer à cette
possibilité de pénuries
alors c'est vrai que au niveau là on a
connu une pénurie catastrophique en
début de crise allait bien on avait on
n'avait pas de masse du conte a mis en
place deux dotations d'état
c'est l'état qui a distribué les masses
comme ça dans les pharmacies pour les
pros finale de santé parce qu'on n'avait
pas d'autre solution
aujourd'hui les fournisseurs médicaux ou
des masques dont qu'on arrive à se
fournir auprès de fournisseurs habituels
donc ça c'est une bonne chose
on a des pénuries sur les gants par le
mois mais pour les prochaines de santé
pour les pour les jours fériés c'est
très compliqué de travailler son temps
et je peux vous dire que on a une grosse
pénurie et au niveau des gants donc des
masques mois et d'écran c'est vraiment
compliqué et puis sur sur les masques et
bien le problème c'est qu'il n'arrive à
les avoir
mais ils sont encore très cher et c'est
vrai que l'on utilise 4 5 masques par
jour alors sur sur un mois des masques à
peu près 1 euro pièce donc sur un mois
ça fait délais des sommes et donc je
comprends que certains professionnels de
santé à la demande à ce que le
gouverneur gouvernement les aides alors
des dotations se termine je ne m'en va
aider est ce que vous pensez justement
qu'un gouvernement va aider il ya cette
flambée des prix pour les masses mais
aussi les gants alors c'est vrai qu'il
est tout à fait ils font des crises sur
les gants et sur les masques et du coup
ça occasionne pour nous aider des
surcoûts assez assez important et je
pense qu'il serait de bon augure
effectivement d'envisager une prime
particulière pour aider les procès de
santé libéraux dans l'achat de leur
profil dans leur outil de travail et de
protection
quelles seraient les possibles
conséquences et aucun durcissement des
mesures n'était mis en place un deuxième
confinement peut être un peu plus adapté
à à l'économie peut-être plus adapté à
l'économie parce que on sait que c'est
un désastre économique et social
derrière et donc je pense que léa les
pouvoirs publics veulent absolument
éviter tout confinement nationale du
moins alors peut-être déconfinement pas
réel mais je crois qu'ils ont les seuils
aussi d éviter
et c'est pour ça que martel à l'opinion
publique qu'il faut absolument porter
les masques le plus possible parce que
c'était un vrai un vrai outil de
conduire pour couronner le seul en fait
vraiment efficaces pour stopper la
décontamination et aussi le lavage des
mains on en parle un peu moins mais
c'est aussi important parce que les
gouttelettes
quand on parle elles se transmettent
dans l'air mais après leur tombait donc
définitive il faut aussi continuer ses
gestes barrières un cabinet à la carte
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
bon courage à vous je rappelle que vous
êtes le fondateur du groupement action
soit infirmée